welcome to this video playing camp I and
from young some South American land
Venezuela maybe Colombia yeah nope not
so far at least okay so we got a ruler
pass by transposition the Steinitz
variation we have an outdated line but
not necessarily so bad it's a bit
passive but mmm but this really I don't
really maybe I get this counter attack
on e four so I wasn't winning on d5 okay
yeah this is known back back from the
day from Alaska tirage and matches like
that in the nineteen the early 20th
century 1906 1908 something like that ok
he didn't take on b5 surprisingly so I'm
going to take this Bishop way to
everyone trying to keep more pieces on
the board as black as a bit cramped in
the center and then the question is how
to develop now can go well be three
Bishop b2 with an interesting way to
develop I wonder about d5 though maybe
you can play either cannot i think
because of his seven hanging aha so he's
going to try to regroup ok Bishop to f6
probably know I'm dropping back yeah
that's a fairly solid position for black
it's not very young
very active but certainly playable yeah
how to proceed would like to get of
course yeah somewhere the night to d5
but without okay blundering be to hit
without exchanging it as well not quite
sure how
yeah I think I probably need f3 anyway
so I'll play that and I'm thinking about
maybe Bishop a3 and 95 then does he
really want to put a piece on deform or
Bishop g5 ok then I have Queen f2 ok
I'll do that this is just to prepare
night to d5 without exposing the beat to
bishop Oh interesting this is a vicious
way to play Queen a try but I have g3
write this I shouldn't worry me so much
but just yeah well this is not so clear
their property should take hear you
Queen takes Queen edge for would have
been bit bit annoying now Queen edge for
I can really play g3 without any big
problem yeah what does he doing really
Quincy five maybe Queen g5 coming but I
don't really understand it to be honest
if I go g3 and therefore I just have a
big advantage in the center Quincy five
I go King edge one then them then what
exactly yeah I think I'm plucky needs to
retreat it to 2g 60s and now probably
just a form and yeah what now that this
is interesting maybe you simply take
only a droopy one check because of the
bishop pair I don't have any objection
to to trading down to two heavy pieces
only but I have some problems with my
king is a bit bit open so on this is
something to to consider especially with
Queens on this could be a problem I'm
trying to do that here get him to
exchange while I control the e-file yeah
if he goes Queenie 7 now yet somehow
expected that it will be this rather
one-sided endgame I hope so see form
check yeah yeah we can do to d3 but to
e3 I mean that I have Bishop d3
controlling everything nicely night do
you want to see three SS maybe an idea
yeah but it shouldn't that shouldn't
really be a problem
yeah you hip he almost must do that the
night has nowhere else to go I wonder
okay now it he has given given it a
square but if I go we should see one
what what happens after that f5 is
dropping right he cannot go naija for I
take on f5 9h to change due to its
trapped yeah I think he needed to try 91
to see three it could be a it could be M
a journey without any return tickets but
yeah okay this is just a window cannot
cannot really go anywhere from g4 has to
to drop back I think
yeah it has no square from from F to how
to to do that yeah maybe we should be
three as the easiest am check time
warning okay King here right after King
into us to distract ya to h1 you can
still go to h1 black resigns yeah I
don't I really think the end game unless
they hear something concrete very
directly this this end game missus is
quite quite a problem maybe he can check
my am NOT not night f5 95 is already
quite wrong I believe he could try to
keep it close stare like like with f5 or
something like that f5 g6 king of seven
trying to block everything but okay um
the two bishops are quite quite a
problem here this is some somewhat
comparable to some end games that arise
from the Kings Indian Kings Indian
Arabic their the cornice on c5 and why
it is known to be a much more
comfortable in this type of structure
h3g for immune to to to gain lots of
space but this would have been much
tougher or a thing here here it's a bit
of a journey with no return after this
this is directly losing which probably
needs to go here and try to do something
with 93 but I am I have my doubts bishop
see one it's useful anyway the bishop is
bad on a three and now it gets tricky if
you go here
you really don't know where to go from
them that's a it's a big problem and
sometimes even the traders this is an
issue something that will lose the night
again this is trapped him cannot go
anywhere here maybe maybe you should try
to avoid this many exchanges all
together but here this this capture is
just not good it's helping me enormously
because now the pieces here are getting
pushed back after night F for q3 edge of
F for all this is coming with the temple
and at the end i have this have this
notorious bishop Pam it's not not really
good shouldn't allow that ok thanks for
watching